- Live and direct from
Hollywood, it's Thanksgiving!
- We're gonna go check out some of
the weirdest Thanksgiving stuff in L.A,
which I'm really excited about.
- We're gonna have three
Thanksgiving meals,
in one day. Lets do this,
it's gonna be awesome.
- I fucking love Thanksgiving!
(shouting)
- And I brought my secret
weapon, it's in this bag.
- [Colin] Look at you, Mr. Suspense.
(festive music)
Thanksgiving in my family is generally
very traditional and
there's a lot of football.
- Family time, friend time,
and just being able to chill.
- My parents are immigrants from Malaysia.
Thansgiving, to us, is a great time
to hangout and eat hot pot.
- We are about to roll up on the Oinkster,
where we're gonna eat
Thanksgiving turkey burgers.
- Where the buns are made out of stuffin'.
- Oh no, that's the
only thing I don't like.
- What?
- We're looking for the coolest,
craziest, wildest Thanksgiving dish.
- The Burger of the Month is
actually the Turducken Burger.
A lot of flavor.
(laughing)
- [Steven] Can I give you a hug?
I hate hugs, but this looks amazing.
Thank you so much.
- [Freddie] Thank you guys so much.
- [Steven] A turducken
is three patties of meat,
on top of each other.
- [Colin] Duck pastrami,
turkey burger, chicken.
- [Steven] Fried chicken burger.
- Cheers, guys.
- [All together] Cheers!
- [Colin] It's delicious
before it even hit my mouth.
- [Freddie] I have chills.
- Wow.
- It's so well constructed.
The flavors melt into each other.
- It tastes like the holiday season.
What's our rubric here?
- [Voiceover] Creativity.
- [Voiceover] I'd give
it an eight and a half.
- Are you kidding me?
Turducken?
10!
This is a nine in holiday spirit.
- Turduck-ten, is what
we're talking about here.
From a Steven to a Freddie,
how wild is this burger?
- I'd give it an eight on wild factor,
if it was spicy at all.
No, I'm gonna give it
a seven on wild factor.
Yeah, you're right.
Monster, you're doing it right.
- Love it?
- Love it.
- Next up, we've got our
good friends at Dog Haus.
- Dog Haus specializes in hot dogs.
You hate on hot dogs.
- [Steven] No, no, no, no.
They're great, but burgers are better.
Colin, what do you think?
- We are here for that.
Do you eat hot dogs on Thanksgiving?
- We do here at Dog Haus.
- Yeah?
We're going to eat
their Turducken Special,
which has smoked turducken sausage,
sage gravy, brussel sprouts, bacon slaw,
crispy onions, all on a Hawaiian roll.
I think I would be the turkey,
because it's the biggest.
- I'm chicken because
I'm the most basic here.
- She's the duck because she's smooth.
- Or she quacks a lot.
- Whoa!
- [Steven] I did not expect that.
- [Freddie] Yep, Happy Thanksgiving!
- [Steven] Happy Thanksgiving.
- Don't wanna wear white
pants if you eat this, huh?
- [Steven] Whoa, how does it (mumbling).
- Yeah, there's like funny little
niblets inside the sausage.
- Look at this niblet.
- I think it's carrots.
Creativity here is obviously a 10.
I've never seen anything quite like this.
A full oral experience,
you got the good bread,
you've got everything.
- It's like if you combine
Fourth of July and Thanksgiving,
this is what you'd get.
- Holiday vibe, I'd give it a five.
- I would order this anytime of year.
- Wild factor.
I'd give this a nine.
- Have you ever seen a hot dog like this?
- No.
- Then how is this not a 10?
- Because I think that there's
gotta be room for growth.
- Yeah.
- It's turducken.
- You love saying that word.
- Turducken.
- He just loves the word turducken.
Now we're gonna do Thanksgiving
ice cream at Salt and Straw.
You're gonna have to roll me home.
- For real, look at his stomach.
- We just pulled up.
We're gonna eat Thanksgiving
themed ice cream.
If it's turkey flavored, I'm gonna barf.
- [Freddie] I could be into some
cranberries or some sweet potatoes.
- [Colin] Sweet potato?
- [Steven] It's poh-tato.
- It's not poh-tato.
Nobody says that.
- It's poh-tato.
- Our head ice cream maker Tyler
and his team have turned the entire
Thanksgiving table into ice cream.
So we've got sweet
potato with maple pecan.
- Wait, wait, say that again.
- Sweet potato.
- Sweet poh-tato.
- Salted caramel ice cream
made with turkey fat,
instead of butter, and
turkey skin that's been
turned into a crispy candy brittle.
- No.
- Yeah.
- Do you guys perhaps have
a bathroom around here?
- [Freddie] Oh, he's pulling
out his secret weapon.
- Yes.
Steven brought his prop
Thanksgiving pants.
I'm embarrassed on your behalf.
- How's the sweet potato?
(moaning)
This is what Thanksgiving tastes like.
- Yeah.
Mashed potato and gravy.
- I'm upset about that one.
- Yeah.
- Hell no.
- It tastes exactly like
mashed potatoes and gravy.
I can't do it.
I'm sorry the gravy
- Oh, the after taste.
- We're gonna eat meat
flavored ice cream right now.
- It's not just flavored.
There's meat inside the ice cream.
You look sad.
- It's kinda weird, right?
- [Freddie] I don't get it.
- Oh, that's the worst.
- Ambitious move to do
Thanksgiving ice cream.
- Wild factor?
- 10.
- 11.
- Yeah, they went so wild that they like,
went off the wild charts.
- All in all, these ice creams in general,
were pretty pleasant.
Sweet potato.
- Poh-tato.
- I'm gonna throw you in
front of a moving vehicle.
- First lesson learned,
bring your sweat pants.
- Yeah, I could use a pair of sweat pants,
these jeans are chafing right now.
We learned that Thanksgiving
can come in many forms.
- Many, many forms.
- But the best form is turducken.
- You guys, we basically
just had a Friendsgiving.
- We did.
- Until next time.
- Wear your sweat pants.
- It's here, it's here.
- [All together] It's here.
- It's here.
- Get it.
- There.
- I think I got it, get it.
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here.